to talk about Harvey Weinstein for a
second because you were very vocal very
one of the leaders of the times that
movement when you saw him in handcuffs
Natalie what did you think well I think
it was you know unfortunately you
there's not a win in the situation so
many people have been so hurt but it's
it is important for us to see that
there's consequences even for the most
powerful of the abusers there were there
will be consequences and and I think
that's important I went back and look
there's like what Weinstein movies or
Miramax movies was Natalie Portman in
and it was that 96 drama beautiful girls
and your co-stars were uma Thurman
Lauren Holly and Mira Sorvino
I know I was I went so many of those
women came forward it was crazy to think
I was 13 years old on a set where I
although all the women around me were
being really really hurt and I was lucky
to be oblivious to that but it's it was
I think such a big wake-up call of
course for all of us and and yes and I'm
glad that there's consequences but
unfortunately I wish it just didn't
happen and and hopefully the
consequences will prevent and deter
other other people from abusing their
power and the conversation continues
Natalie Portman wonderful to have you
here so much thank you for being here
and